الفنان محمد سعد بيشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني في مسلسل اكسلانس ومن اسبوعين
انتشر فيديو من موقع التصوير قلب الدنيا
وعمل جدل كبير وفي ظهر الفنان وهو بيصرخ
وببهدل الناس في موقع التصوير واليوم
الموضوع يعني صار في تطورات بس خليني اول
اذكركم بالمشهد
فيه ده ايه العرض ده انتوا مقرفين قوي
ده
انتم
ايه اللي مش عاجبه يقول
اللي مش عاجبه يقول
الفيديو اللي شفتوه عمل جدل وانقسام كثار
انتقدوا اذان وقالوا عيب وفنانين دخلوا
على الخط دعما
وصاروا ينشروا صورهم مع محمد سعد وتضاربت
الانباء حول اللي صاير في الفيديو فاحد
قال انه كان بيصرخ على الطاقم بما فيهم
المخرج ابرام نشاته مخرج العمل يعني طلعت
على لسانه تصريحات مختلفه فالمصري اليوم
مثلا نقلوا عنه انه محمد سعد ما كان بيصرخ
على العاملين في المسلسل بل على الناس من
خارج اللوكيشن عطلوا التصوير لكن شفنا
وسائل اعلان تانيه ناقله عن المخرج تصريح
مختلف بيقول في انه مشكله محمد سعد كانت
مع المسؤولين عن السيطره على المكان اثناء
التصوير وهو انفعل بسبب فقدهم للسيطره
عليها وفي تصريح ثالث قال المخرج انه محمد
سعد كان منفعل لانه طلب من طاقم الانتاج
امور وما صارت الجديد اليوم انه نقيب
الفنانين اشرف زكي طلع ودافع عن محمد سعد
وقال انه محمد وقت ما يشارك في اي عمل
بيكون مسؤول عنه تماما وبيتحمل مسؤوليته
وانه اهتمامهم بالعمل بيكون كبير جدا وقال
انه هو شاف الفيديو وانو اللي يعرفوا انه
كان في اشياء طلبها وما تنفذت وانه ما
يعرف بالتحديد على مين كان منفعل وانه
محمد سعد انسان محترم وابن بلد وان كان
اخطاء فلازم نغفر له الفيديو اللي تسرب مو
كامل ومشتهزق ونحن شفنا رد الفعل بس وليس
الفعل
[موسيقى]